so I want to start today with what's
really fundamentally an infrastructure
story but also a story about how we
often sort of Miss the forest for the
trees or we end up wrapped up in a
detail when the bigger story is really
the big picture many of you might have
heard about this bridge collapse that
took place in Pittsburgh and because of
the timing of a Joe Biden trip to
Pennsylvania it immediately became very
very political we're even going to look
at a clip on Fox news of a couple of
anchors there talking about the collapse
and Joe Biden's infrastructure Bill and
uh just getting at just about every
single fact wrong but before we get to
that I think it's important to remind
you guys that when we talk about
infrastructure and the fact that the US
is woefully behind on infrastructure
spending that infrastructure spending
which in many countries is not political
in the U.S is so politicized and
partisan
that we have hundreds of bridges with
the exact same rating as the Pittsburgh
bridge that collapsed and yet we only
talk about the issue in real serious
terms when a bridge actually collapses
when we have debates about
infrastructure
it is mentioned in passing hey we have
many bridges that need to be up you know
repaired uh brought back uh modernized
Etc but it's almost like it doesn't
really exist until there's a bridge
collapse and case in point there's a
very good article on new jersey.com
nj.com which points out nearly 500 New
Jersey Bridges received the same poor
rating
as the one that collapsed in Pittsburgh
and this is for New Jersey and it has a
map so you can see which which are
nearby but it points out on the fhwa's
National Bridge inventory for 2021
482 Garden State Bridges received a
grade of poor that's the same rating as
the bridge in Pittsburgh's Frick Park
that collapsed on Friday morning
injuring 10 people
States federal agencies and tribal
governments submit data to the bridge
inventory on an annual basis about seven
percent of Jersey Bridges have that poor
grade
27 are good which is the highest rating
and the rest are somewhere in between
uh each Bridge receives ratings on its
deck superstructure substructure and
Culvert
um etc etc so also important is that
many of these are Railway bridges over
which trains are uh transiting so
obviously most of these Bridges rated
poor are not going to collapse
um I saw a comment from a bridge
engineer who has explained that also you
can't always tell by looking at a bridge
which category it's in that there's lots
of bridges that look very bad
cosmetically but structurally are
actually in that category good even
though if if you or I looked at it we
would say that that's an absolute
disaster but there are lots of these
Bridges with the exact same rating
actual structural rating as the
Pittsburgh bridge that collapsed now of
course it probably won't collapse when
you or I or any one vehicle goes over it
usually it doesn't happen but it reminds
us that we have a primarily reactive
economy in the United States and this is
different than in many other countries
there's countries where you find this
but there's many European countries that
have a different approach in the U.S
certainly among the right
sometimes on the left as well
spending money before there's a problem
is seen as uh imprudent it's seen as a
waste of money and often the money
doesn't get spent until something falls
down or somebody dies first it's similar
in health care why make insurance
companies cover all of this optional
preventive stuff treat sick people well
no but that's the whole point the
optional preventive stuff keeps people
healthier on average and it avoids some
of that big spending later half the
country at least in terms of the
political reality
uh just doesn't accept that whether they
believe it or not they don't accept it
as a way to actually do politics and
it's the exact same principle here uh
when it comes to these uh bit Bridges
but bigger picture with infrastructure
spending overall which is when you look
at that list and remember when we just
had the debate over infrastructure you
look at that list and so many on the
right and some on the left look at that
list and they go this stuff it's it's
not really infrastructure spending how
is it infrastructure spending where we
are reacting to a particular storm by
saying we're gonna bring all of this
stuff up to new code that's not really
recovery that's a that's something these
are pet projects no it's the same
Principle as with health care and even
with this what it took this one bridge
collapse to get people thinking in
slightly different terms about these
things but looking just at New Jersey
and you have 500 Bridges with the exact
same rating and it hopefully it doesn't
happen frequently
but it's just a matter of time until it
happens again
there are sort of like um obscure
anti-vax people that have died during
the pandemic you know I'll mention to
you oh this uh you know Deputy County
Commissioner I don't even remember what
she was in California who went to an
anti-vaxx rally and posted some anti-vax
stuff on her Facebook she now died of
covet but typically most of those folks
are not like known to us and when
they're known to us they're often not
known as anti-vaxx people there's an
incredible new story which dozens of you
sent me over the weekend about a
Washington state police officer
who was sort of a celebrity anti-vaxxer
this was not an obscure random officer
Robert Lemay
quit his job as a Washington state
trooper because he didn't want to get
vaccinated during his sign off which we
will look at he told the Governor Jay
Inslee to kiss his ass he was on Fox
News being interviewed by Laura Ingram
as if he was some kind of hero for
quitting over the vaccine mandate he's
dead of covet
he's dead of covet state trooper who
told Governor to kiss my ass over
vaccine mandate dies of covet 19. this
is from two days ago Robert Lemay 51
famously signed off in his squad car
after 22 years of service in October
just a few months ago while blasting
Democratic Governor Jay Inslee the
governor had mandated state workers get
vaccinated against covet not unique to
the state of Washington Lemay died on
Friday here is his principled and
defiant sign off where he also sends a
shot across the bow at the Governor Jay
Inslee I wish I could say more but um
this is it so State 1034 this is the
last time you'll hear me in a state
patrol car and James Lee can kiss my ass
wow what a principled and defiant action
that this guy took
um once again he was also known to the
Fox News Community here he is being
interviewed by Laura Ingram and getting
a hero's welcome this was in October
right around the time that he did this
uh stun oh
the vaccination staff the Border when we
had
the people waved in and one you know a
two-week period so they don't seem too
concerned about that Robert uh what's
next for you other than being a
celebrity now what's next for you yeah
other than catching covet and dying
right
you know so I'm overwhelmed um I really
am I'm a pretty private person
um and um my son's in the military I'm
like son this is what's happening he
goes all right Dad I'm going black
um so it's we're just trying to put our
feet on the ground and it's funny we're
we're very religious people and we
prayed about all this when this first
started you know Lord what do you want
us to do and notice that the prayer did
not save him from covet and that's uh
again
oh is did he not pray correctly did he
not pray hard enough did he do other
things wrong so that God did not answer
his prayers because for all the prayer
he died of covet it's our path and
um we've had applications out of state
and all types of stuff but Lord never
really pointed us to one point so we
said okay maybe this is the fight well
then that came out and it went viral and
I'm like okay this is where you want us
to do right now so I'm the spokesperson
for thousands and thousands I even say
millions of people I think there's two
million people that have actually viewed
it
um it's been 99 positive from everybody
um I think this is my path right now um
there's a lot of job offers that I'm
getting phenomenal job offers all right
well I'm a sleeping giant yeah well
maybe a sleep a sleeping job all right
so and there uh Laura Ingram Cuts him
off she's had enough of it so what was
next for Robert Lemay was catching covet
on vaccinated and dying and of course as
I've said before we we can't say for
sure about any end of visual he would
have survived had he been vaccinated we
can't we you can't ever say that about a
particular person
statistically because the vaccines are
so effective at preventing serious
illness and death
all those great job offers that he was
getting all of this celebrity welcome
and all of the he would have been able
to carry it out had he just been
vaccinated but of course had he been
vaccinated he never would have become
the anti-vaxx hero in the first place
the takeaway here guys is this is a
cautionary tale we're not dancing on his
grave the the cautionary tale is no
matter how Brazen your rhetoric is no
matter how alpha you believe yourself or
others believe you to be because of your
job or because of your physical
appearance or whatever
covid might kill you and so we have one
tool that really reduces the odds of
that and it's the vaccine this guy chose
to forego it it was because of his
prayer to God not because of Any valid
medical reason or anything else he has
now died of covet celebrity anti-backs
cop who told Jay Inslee to kiss his ass
is dead and he will not be working any
of those other jobs we'll take a quick
break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you
who sign up on our website
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members and I would love for
you to sign up you can use the coupon
code wow22 to get a sizable discount and
you'll become a member instantly you can
once again do that at joinpakman.com
over the weekend Donald Trump held his
second
2022 rally these rallies now are very
clearly 2022 focused other than still
being focused on the 2020 election which
Donald Trump continues to claim falsely
that he won but the the rallies are
getting far more dangerous far more
Insidious and corrosive they're now
actually starting to uh sort of tease
the idea of more riots in the future if
Trump doesn't get what he wants Trump
also dangling pardons for the January 6
22 21 rioters at this rally and the
dangerous part is
I don't want to say it's not the
dangerous part is partially that the
rally exists and the things that Donald
Trump says but it's hugely that there's
a crowd of people who go there thousands
of people who want to hear this stuff
now we had two people on the ground at
the rally they filmed some very
disturbing interviews including one
individual who admitted that he was in
the capital on January 6th and we of
course will be turning that over to law
enforcement we'll have those videos for
you tomorrow we had Luke Beasley and
Josh Pitt on the ground for today we're
going to look at what the rally actually
consisted of now of course the the
framing of the rally is always a lie in
this case it was that there were 85 000
people at the rally there were not 85
000 people there there were thousands
though and that already should concern
all of us and in particular some of the
claims Donald Trump made are
particularly authoritarian and fascistic
you know a principle of authoritarians
is they don't respect the law they use
the law as a tool when they can use it
for their personal gain but when the law
is an obstacle to their personal gain
they say they will go around the law and
that's exactly what Donald Trump did now
before we even get to that
um Trump really struggling through this
one the teleprompter reading losing his
place getting confused just a couple
examples to set the stage for you know
again in this case Trump's right eye
swollen almost completely shut and he
looked confused by what was on the
prompter here's just one example
[Music]
speaking the truth while they drown your
endless torment of I mean what they do
they have an endless
list of propaganda and propaganda
methods so a lot of that during the
entire rally here's Trump referring to
the country of Mexico
the biggest beneficiaries it's such a
good deal that Mexico and Canada you saw
that Mexico and Canada want to get out
of it and then lastly Donald Trump uh
also looking extremely confused talking
about the Sinister faces of corruption
Lawless
this is incredible
but their Sinister faces of
corruption
Lawless
yeah just losing his place frequently
but let's get to the substance maybe the
craziest part of this is that Donald
Trump says if he is re-elected he may
um pardon people and he is threatening
unrest let's start there Trump actually
threatening more riots
if these radical vicious racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal
I hope we are going to have in this
country the biggest protest we have ever
had in Washington DC in New York in
Atlanta and elsewhere because our
country and our elections are corrupt so
he sang there if the prosecution of the
Trump rioters continues in a way I will
say is unfair which he's already doing
then we need to do more of these
so-called biggest protests and at this
point
everybody knows what that means
everybody understands that he's not
talking about peaceful protests he's
talking about more riots and maybe even
more pernicially perniciously Trump says
if he's re-elected he's going to look at
pardons for the people who did the
rioting
[Music]
when you were a six fairly we will treat
them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so unfairly now that is not
due process and the rule of law that is
politically these people are on my side
so we're going to come in and give them
pardons even though I don't really know
anything about their individual cases
and the the important thing here is
consider how jarring this is in
comparison to the original story that it
wasn't even really trumpists that were
there it was antifa and black lives
matter the first story was it wasn't
trumpists it was antifa dressed as
trumpists it was black lives matter
dressed as trumpets there were some
peaceful Trump supporters maybe but they
certainly didn't do anything wrong then
they shifted into it was a false flag
done by the FBI
uh Ray Epps and it was a Tucker pushed
this story then for a little while it
was I guess the FBI and antifa now it
was trumpists all of a sudden I guess
but Trump will pardon them because
they're not getting a fair Shake they're
not being treated fairly so I guess it
wasn't antifa or more realistically it
no longer matters to the story because
now the new one is elect me and I will
pardon these people now I many of you
probably would think if I told you Trump
bragged about his dementia test again
you'd say but yeah but David it's almost
February of 2022 but didn't he take that
test like in the middle of 2020 he's not
what you'd you would be right he's still
bragging about the dementia test take a
look at this you know are getting a
little nasty they didn't like that we
were doing so well
so they said maybe this guy's not with
it and I said Ronnie can I take some
kind of a test is there something like
you can sir but it's very hard now the
number of times Trump says sir during a
story
is directly proportional to uh it's
inversely proportional to the truth of
the story so the more he says sir the
more untrue the story is we figured that
out and there's a lot of sirs here I
30th pretty hard sir I said well would
anyone know if I did badly right
he said well you know it is Walter Reed
a lot of people see what's happening I
better do well even that's interesting
because basically what Trump's saying is
why don't I take it and if I don't do
well we just don't release it
I think I said
[Music]
now it's really again it's important
Trump says I did well in my life so
let's do a cognitive test the test it's
the Montreal cognitive assessment it's
just meant to screen for serious
dementia whether you did well in school
or not doesn't actually have a bearing
on whether you are now suffering from a
medical condition he still doesn't get
it
and as Ronnie said I got every single
question right he said I aced it and you
know
from that point on they didn't talk they
found other things and they said he
wants to be a dictator he wants to be
they went on to other things but I think
Biden should do the same thing Ronnie
would you administer the test please it
would solve so many problems I have a
feeling he won't be doing it anytime
soon do you agree but seriously Ronnie
Jackson so there it's still a topic a
president a former president bragging
about how he passed the dementia test
then Donald Trump complained that
prosecutors are out there to get Trump
unfairly this causes the crowd to chant
lock her up about Hillary but how
jarring is it that Trump's saying
there's prosecutorial misconduct against
me and meanwhile the crowd is chanting
to lock up Hillary who hasn't even been
charged with a crime I thought he was
about due process I guess not local
prosecutors in New York and other
locations who horribly campaigned for
office on we're gonna get Trump
This Is How They campaign we're going to
get Trump they know nothing about me
we're gonna get them then got elected
and are working overtime to fulfill
their campaign promises they've
subpoenaed more than
it's it's really something I mean he
says these prosecutors aren't behaving
correctly we have we everything needs to
be done the right way yet lock up
Hillary who's not even been accused
never mind charged of any crime uh Trump
doing his supply chain stuff of course
can you believe what's happening you
can't get anything the shelves are empty
I did a book they can't publish it
anymore they can't get the paper the
glue the ink
go out and buy it you'll like it every
opportunity to promote his book is an
opportunity Trump takes and then lastly
maybe the one bit of truth from the
rally Trump says when Republicans retake
Congress they will investigate the Biden
family that he's probably telling the
truth about I do believe they will do
that and Biden has the real scandals and
rest assured when Republicans we take
Congress to Biden corruption will be
investigated and exposed by Congress
but we no longer have a free and fair
press if we did all of this would end it
would yeah
um I think he's that's the that's the
one piece I think he's telling the truth
about as I've said before I believe if
Republicans win in November they will
investigate Biden they will investigate
Biden's family they may even impeach Joe
Biden won't convict in the Senate but
they may even impeach Joe Biden so an
extraordinarily corrosive rally and
these are going to continue he is going
to play a role in 2022 later in the show
I'll tell you about uh or or tomorrow
rather new polling is not so good for
Trump among the Republican party but
it's certainly not stopping the rallies
so the first part of the problem we're
now experiencing in the country is we
still have Trump running around saying
uh corrosive and damaging things about
our democracy and it's a real problem
the reason we worry about it is because
thousands of people still go to the
rallies and the guy still has millions
of followers and I'm gonna play some
clips for you of interviews done with
Trump rally goers on Saturday in Conroe
Texas and this is really about a lot of
things what what I'm going to play for
you is very disturbing if there's kids
in the room you may not want them to see
this stuff but this is about education
this is about untreated mental illness
in some cases you'll see that it's about
the weaponizing of vulnerable people by
politicians it's about a lot of
different things but at the very top of
the list it's about this kind of
coalescing of people with the absolute
worst instincts to allow authoritarian
strong men wannabes like Trump to put in
place any vision of the country even one
where there is no due process there is
no freedom of the press so we lack all
of those things under this Grand Vision
of people like Trump and the people
either because they don't understand or
they're distracted with other things or
because they're mentally ill
they allow it to go on because if Trump
wants it it must be okay
let's just start with this first clip I
won't even introduce it do you do your
rich on this right
this round Global plan to enslave you
and your family and pretty much make you
poor independent upon a global
government
something I like to call evil so it's
even bigger than that no it's spiritual
warfare I think it's written about in
this book it's a really popular book A
lot of people read it I think the Bible
Bible Revelation right you can't buy or
sell without the mark so is this a
religious delusion is this mental
illness if you're watching you'll notice
a guy with a sign behind these folks
that says Mass formation psychosis which
is sort of the New Meme for them it can
become very difficult to discern what is
merely a psychotic break and delusional
beliefs and paranoid schizophrenia and
what is a religious nut and what is
someone who's just been brainwashed I
mean I'm not joking about these things
it's very tough here's another one of
these everybody's happy and everybody's
got one goal and that's for everybody to
love everybody
and save our save our country live their
best lives
unpopular opinion I'm a letters are so
uh like I just been talking to some
people today telling them why I believe
what I believe it's like I try to find
common ground on uh because most people
would agree that we don't come from
monkeys and that we didn't Big Bang
right so I can tell you guys this guy is
definitely this guy definitely didn't
big bang I would I would I would concede
that but
um this is what do we make of that is
this is this a sick person or or what is
it if you can find common ground with
people then you can start building a
foundation of like what truth is you
know so and let's go right uh so sort of
quite a contrast right we didn't come
from monkeys we didn't Big Bang let's
find truth
and let's go Brandon here's another
woman
um asked about who knows something she's
holding a huge Trump head it's like uh
four feet tall the size of Trump's uh
that that's the size of this Trump head
that she's holding so that's what that's
what all this is
[Music]
your first Trump rally
[Music]
Tulsa Oklahoma and April and it was a
freedom Fest and Clay Clark's reawaken
America Tour and it was about educating
people that some of the ideas that we're
going through need to be researched a
little deeper there's way too much false
information that's true the problem is
she's coming up on the wrong end of it
and you need to educate yourself on
health educate yourself on your water
educate yourself on what you put in your
body and that's a personal choice that
they should not have the right to take
that away from us
absolutely I couldn't agree more well
keep using your voice keep keep speaking
whenever I want to know the truth when I
want to educate myself when I want to
dig deeper I go to someone who's holding
a four foot tall cardboard Trump head I
mean it's just Perfectly Natural guys
um then he goes up to some kid and you
can tell this guy's been been read the
riot act on fake news listen to this
time what do you think about the way the
media just goes for broke on their lies
I think
that people should stop listening in the
media right and watch y'all's stuff
because y'all don't lie about anything
right and watch Republican news I mean
there's some news networks that are just
Democrat in their brainwashing the
people right just watch Republican news
and right side broadcasting and then
you'll know the truth you'll know
everything
um lastly or no not lastly I got a
couple more for you here's a woman in a
box she wore a box and she really misses
Trump's tweets her entire life used to
be wrapped up in Trump's tweets
he was kicked off Twitter I mean I miss
those tweets do you what are you doing
every single day of my life that's what
I spent doing for five years what a sad
life huh literally I mean it's
everything I did and I miss him terribly
and the people miss them terribly that's
the sad thing hear me out again another
business idea everybody misses Trump's
tweets her entire life for five years
went around Trump's tweets all right now
I don't know if it goes from funny to
scary maybe it wasn't even funny to
begin with here's a woman who thinks
that Joe Biden was actually killed two
years ago at Guantanamo Bay and that
there is now a fake Joe Biden why why
are you here what's your motivation
she's our real president thank you very
much and what what are you basing that
on what happened to the election was
stolen and he's our real president
the real Biden was assassinated 2019
March of 2019. so it's only that so
listen to the number of Lies Trump's the
real president Trump actually won the
real Buy Biden was assassinated or as
she says and assassinated two years ago
[Music]
the world what was crooked
but Trump's having 40 50 60 000 people
at his rallies before the presidency or
for the election and Biden has 50 people
and that includes the people there for
security and the media all together and
he supposedly got more votes than Obama
correct so how do you explain that
because the American people men who were
really president is we're fighting for
America and we are going to save this
country in the world and people know
that if I did the pedophile and they
don't want to go see him because they
know he's a pedophile tell my creepy Joe
creepy Joseph did you know that he had
an island his family has an island near
Epstein like eight miles away I didn't
know his family it's called water Island
yeah there's no family
he has like a um kind of like a little
Neverland called Michael Jackson no
Michael Jackson was saving the children
they destroyed
even that the guy tries to agree the guy
goes yeah Biden's got a pedophile Island
kind of like Michael Jackson's Neverland
and she goes no no no no no no Michael
Jackson was not doing anything wrong he
was saving the kids Michael Jackson I
thought for years he was on the bad side
he's not he was saving the children and
when he plays at the inauguration
when Michael Jackson comes and plays for
us people are going to realize so she
thinks Michael Jackson's alive I think
so he had a big cue Neverland he had
that big cue shaving the children Trump
helped him Escape
he helped John F Kennedy Junior escaping
up Princess Diana Escape so John F
Kennedy Jr and Princess Diana are also
alive how how is this even you know
we're up against the political movement
that's filled with people with no
connection to reality undiagnosed and
certainly untreated mental illness at
least in some cases
um here's the last one about a satanic
system that we're in that is pure evil
good versus evil it's not left right
it's not Democratic and I believe that
too right now you know what I'm saying
I'm saying I think I think this um uh uh
system that we got going on right now is
the satanic system uh uh system yeah and
let me tell you something and let me
tell you something I believe I believe
Satan is on his j-o-b man he is on his
j-o-b and we need to be getting on
without j-o-b we got to take this
country back for God man
we gotta take this country back for
Jesus Christ man yeah amen yes Darkness
so um always uh you know it's really a
unique mix that is not common in other
countries of lack of Education
religiously based delusions
conspiracism and in some loose sense
mental illness that can include paranoid
schizophrenia and other things that's
I'm not diagnosing any particular
individual we're saying the movement
has all of those things within it how do
you even
run against such a movement that's a
really difficult question to answer
we'll have some of these clips on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show in a new
interview the former Donald Trump
National Security advisor Michael Flynn
says that kovid was intentionally
released by people like George Soros
Klaus Schwab Bill Gates and others in
order to further their goal of ruling
the world and controlling humanity and
defeating Donald Trump of course we're
going to look at a little bit of this
this is this is from Infowars and here's
what I really want you to think about as
you watch this and listen to this this
man was the National Security advisor of
the United States at one point
and that one one point was not that long
ago it was just a few years ago and this
is what he is now saying now I also want
you to think about is he out of his mind
or is he grifting and doesn't believe
this stuff I actually have an opinion
but I'm going to tell you after we look
at the clip is this for real or is he
grifting that's the question the World
Health Organization which has come into
you know into the news quite a bit
because of all this coveted stuff and
the responses but all of these Global
organizations the United Nations is
another one all these Global
organizations they think they see
themselves and and those that are sort
of even above them they see themselves
as this is how we can rule the world
this is how we can control societies
this is how we can control Humanity so
let's introduce something called covid
introduce and they did it and they did
it for a couple of reasons one of the
big reasons was to steal an election I
mean if if the Democrats you know worked
as hard on on uh on foreign policy as
they worked on still in the elections
maybe we would be better off but now of
the the counter to that of course is if
Donald Trump had just dealt with covet
well he would have sailed to re-election
like so many other world leaders did so
covet hurt Trump because he failed but
many world leaders succeeded and sailed
to easy re-elections you know so there's
a
here going on
these are
organizations these are World
organizations and when you start to look
at you know who is who is directing them
and who is leading them uh there are
real people behind that and I you know I
mean
Schwab is one you got a you know George
Soros you have the the Arabella group I
mean these are real things these are
real led by real people who are who have
placed themselves you know Gates is
another one who have placed themselves
above some of the some of these uh World
institutions and they drive them they
really do drive them so this is just
about the craziest most unhinged
hypothesis anyone could come up with
about covid and Soros and Gates and
Klaus Schwab from the world economic
Forum now again without a doubt the
mental illness explanation would surface
here right any more or less normal
person who watches this would consider
um is this a propaganda spreader
or is this a psychotic break and
when you see weaponized trumpism it can
be genuinely difficult to discern
conspiracism from someone experiencing a
psychotic break that's a reality it's
quite a reality and we saw that in the
clips of the people being interviewed at
the Trump rally in the last segment but
but
I think that Flynn is grifting I think
Flynn is definitely grifting here that's
that's my instinct I believe that
Michael Flynn is doing this to drum up I
mean listen
where is he going to get support
he is obviously not going to get it from
the saying left you might find some
wacky people on the left supposedly on
the left like I'm not even going to name
people but some of the usual suspects
that have sort of gone off the deep end
on the left maybe they would see someone
like Flynn and be like this guy's
willing to tell the truth but basically
the left is not going to support him The
Establishment right is not going to
support him because even though he was
pardoned this guy was convicted he did
absolutely horrible things so much of
the right's not going to support him
either so the constit the the potential
constituency for someone like Michael
Flynn to make money from and to get
speaking gigs is going to be the Q Anon
type conspiracy theorist so my instinct
is that he's wacky but that he doesn't
believe this stuff and that this is a
grift the crazy part though is that
there are many people who will watch
this
and hear him talk about it and they'll
go yeah yeah yeah George Soros is
responsible for covet that that makes a
lot of sense to me they'll not along to
it and that's an extraordinarily
disturbing thing
um regardless of whether you believe
vaccines work
uh which they do or whether kovid is
likely to be serious in any particular
population about which we have different
data like regardless of all of those
disagreements that some people have not
using fact to come to conclusions uh
most everybody would agree if if you
have coveted you should stay home right
like you even people who don't want to
get vaccinated mostly believe
covid exists it's contagious and you
should stay home when you have coveted
former Republican congresswoman Michelle
Bachmann is now praising Sarah Palin for
going out to restaurants when she was
contagious and infected with covet last
week
so we're going to look at that just as a
reminder Sarah Palin was seen dining at
a Manhattan Restaurant Elio's Italian
restaurant in the Upper East Side she
had covet at the time
you may remember that the timeline was
and now I want to make sure I have the
timeline right she
um tested positive for covid I believe
it was January 23rd Sunday the 23rd she
had been out to eat in New York on
Saturday the 22nd and then she was seen
within the five-day period during which
you're not supposed to be out she was
seen in the middle of last week on
Wednesday out dining at restaurants we
actually had that clip for you last week
we're just going to take a look at a
little bit of it here with with no audio
I'll describe what we're seeing you see
Sarah Palin sitting at a restaurant one
of these like indoor outdoor outdoor
indoor type scenarios
this also raised the question this
technically is outside but a few days
earlier she had reportedly been indoors
at this restaurant and New York does
require proof of vaccination to dine
indoors the question is is she actually
vaccinated but she's been lying that
she's not ordered the restaurant just
not check for the vaccination okay
whatever the case may be so Michelle
Bachmann is interviewed on Fox News and
she says we should be commending Sarah
Palin for being out with covet
that's what she said take a look he has
different reactions to it but I think
honestly Sarah Palin is to be commended
because she's trying to act like a
normal human being in the greatest city
in America New York City she's going out
to eat at a wonderful little Boutique
Italian restaurant it has different
reactions so that's the view she should
be commended for it now I wonder like
prior to covet right when during flu
season if Michelle Bachmann found out
that a republican was out with the flu
eating at restaurants would they say
that's a great heroic thing to do wow we
should we should really commend her for
being out uh uh with the flu that that's
a really great thing this is getting
more and more stupid every day
and I don't think it's going to turn
around uh soon some people said well
this is Darwinism at its finest it's
really not because Darwinism would be
that this Behavior kills off Palin
before she's able to reproduce she's got
kids already so unfortunately it's not
Darwinism it might just spread the virus
to other people at the restaurant who
did nothing wrong
um but now I mean it it's gotten so
backwards that they are now cheering
people who go out with a highly
contagious virus to restaurants that's
the rock bottom that we have now hit
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so we have an opportunity here to do a
little bit of uh of learning of
Education about how our electoral system
works and some of the nuances in
particulars that some of us may not be
familiar with
the story about Mike Pence's possible
role in the 2020 election is again just
front and center as Donald Trump's new
spokeswoman Liz Harrington posted to
Twitter a statement from Trump going
after Mike Pence saying Pence could have
turned over the election if he wanted
and essentially given it to Trump the
statement put out yesterday from Trump
reads If the vice president Mike Pence
had quote absolutely no right to change
the presidential election results in the
Senate despite fraud and many other
irregularities how come the Democrats
and Rhino Republicans like wacky Susan
Collins are desperately trying to pass
legislation that will not allow the vice
president to change the results of the
election
actually what they are saying is that
Mike Pence did have the right to change
the outcome and they now want to take
that right away unfortunately he didn't
exercise that power he could have
overturned the election now
it's not true that the laws that are
being proposed about the vice
president's role are because the vice
president could overturn the election
it's almost like there's so many
ignorant people that falsely think the
vice president can just decide who wins
that they're looking at putting
something more basic in writing to that
end but we actually have an
infrastructure of law already that makes
it very clear that the vice president's
role with the Electoral College is just
opening the envelopes literally and
figuratively and we're going to get to
that but think about what they're saying
I mean if if what Trump is saying is
correct it means Kamala Harris could
choose the winner of the 2024 election
if she doesn't like who the person that
supposedly won
Kamala could say nope somebody else won
and of course that's not the case the
truth is that uh the vice president does
not have the power to do any of the
things that Donald Trump has hoped that
Pence would have done including you know
seeding an alternate slate of electors
from certain States or any such thing
the 12th Amendment governs this really
really clearly and you can just Google
12th Amendment and read the entire thing
uh it's not very long but the the
important relevant points here are that
the 12th Amendment says the electors
shall meet in their respective States
and vote by ballot for President and
Vice President they shall name in their
ballots the person voted for as
president okay fair
the president of the Senate meaning the
vice remember the VP of the U.S is the
president of the Senate the president of
the Senate shall in the presence of the
Senate and House meaning a joint session
open all the certificates and the votes
shall then be counted that says nothing
about
evaluate whether this is the correct
slate of electors it's the VP shall open
the certificates and the votes shall
then be counted doesn't even say the
vice president will be doing the
counting the votes shall be counted the
person having the greatest number of
votes for president shall be the
president that's it
you then have in addition to the 12th
Amendment the Electoral count Act of
1887. now why in 1887 well uh in 1876
there was a disputed election and in the
roughly 9 10 11 years that followed the
Electoral count Act of 1887 was put
together it also is very clear it number
one puts the onus of resolving disputes
to the states if there are disputes the
state resolves the disputes not the
federal government or the Congress so
for example
if a governor from Arizona certified two
different slates of electors right they
sign off on some democratic electors and
then a slate of Republican electors that
would be a real problem uh if a state
just doesn't certify any electors that
would be a problem that would come to
Congress but 90 of that is States handle
these issues now if you have one of
these extenuating circumstances where
the federal government gets involved
there's a few things Congress can do if
there is a ministerial error
um if there's an elector sent who's not
eligible to be an elector for some
reason if there's a candidate certified
who isn't eligible to be president
um those would be reasons why Congress
can get involved it's very clearly very
limited and to deviate from that
requires powers that the vice president
doesn't have it depends on the House and
Senate it's and that's where all of this
stuff comes from a member of the house
would stand and object and then they
need a member of the Senate to stand and
object with them Etc so the story that
they're telling is not only a dangerous
story uh it's also an untrue story and
what we're up against is that in March
Trump and Pence are both speaking
back-to-back Knights at a republican
committee event in new uh New Orleans
Louisiana and it'll be very interesting
to see if there Trump also slams Pence
and what the crowd reaction would be is
something I would want to see as well
okay this is um I don't want to spend a
lot of time on this this relates to the
bridge collapse in Pittsburgh now at the
top of the show we already talked about
the hundreds of bridges just in New
Jersey that have the same poor rating
as does as did the bridge in Pittsburgh
that collapsed but I want to show you
just like the bottom uh of the barrel
right wing opportunism on this in a
segment on Fox news about the bridge
collapse Fox host or anchor or whatever
Julie Banderas uh said this is what
happens when Joe Biden talks and talks
about an infrastructure Bill and doesn't
get anything done now of course Joe
Biden passed the infrastructure bill but
Julie Banderas apparently didn't know
that notice also that everybody on
screen is just kind of nodding along
you've got Kaylee mcinanny you've got
Arbiter of ideas Dave Rubin and others
take a look at this fairy tales I love
fairy tales I mean but um normally I
only enjoy them when it's during a
bedtime story in the evening not on a
daily basis for the past year since the
White House has been overrun by
democrats but President Biden has been
making promises over promises over
promises and as you've noticed none of
them have come true and when a president
makes promises and then doesn't deliver
and then something like this where bus I
mean there could have been multiple
casualties so thank God nobody was
killed but honestly a bridge collapsing
right before he's back in June of 2021
he started talking about his bipartisan
infrastructure deal there's something
bipartisan about it if it if it was
bipartisan it would have been passed by
now so clearly he's not getting the
message across to the other side of the
aisle which by the way if you remember
during his campaign he said that he was
going to be the president that was going
to reach across the aisle that he was
actually going to make um policy and you
see Kaylee mcinanny there nodding along
now that infrastructure Bill did pass
the bill passed
um months ago it passed in November and
it was bipartisan and that 19 Republican
Senators and 13 Republican
Representatives voted for the bill later
Julie Banderas tweeted that quote
tweeted that she misspoke now she's
since deleted the Tweet because the
Tweet is so stupid but her explanation
was quote I misspoke I was referring to
the president touting the bipartisan
Bill back in June and here we are today
and nothing has improved hence the
bridge collapsed uh now it was so stupid
because it takes a while to actually get
that money and get contracts and
distribute it her criticism was about
Joe Biden and the passage of the bill
now she's saying the criticism is
actually that that bridge wasn't yet
fixed but Biden obviously is no more to
blame for that than the fact that Trump
had four years to do infrastructure and
didn't the bridge problems are major
problems the infrastructure problems are
a disaster I've been talking about it on
the show for a decade there's no
question about that but the initial
claim and the criticism and then the
explanation it's all completely bogus
like this is really the worst of trash
politics she makes a statement made
based on completely
they're not wrong facts it's based on
lies
she takes the statement back but says my
general analysis was still good and it's
considered a correction but it's so
stupid that then she deletes it like
this this is really the worst of the
worst of the worst and unfortunately you
know you've got these bobble heads on
Fox News their heads on a swivel nodding
along even Kaylee mcinanny who has to
know has to know that the bill had
already passed then it passed months ago
and it passed with Republican support as
well this is another one of those
examples where you quite literally will
have brain rot if you just listen to the
analysis they put out and you believe it
yeah Joe Joe Biden's to blame because he
never passed that bill well actually he
did pass it he did pass it and it you
know takes some time uh to get things
done but what about the four years Trump
had
during which he said he was going to do
infrastructure and he didn't well this
is where we end up we have a voicemail
number that number is 219 to David P
this is so funny guys you know how I
sometimes tell you there's a contingent
of the left I use the term revolutionary
leftist or stalinist leninist leftists
some of you prefer more pejorative terms
like Tanki I I just I don't I don't it's
not a term that I use and I pointed out
last week something that to most of you
is now uncontroversial there are
leftists who play Coy with and defend
and sometimes straight up support in the
case of Maduro in Venezuela these
revolutionary authoritarian type figures
that claim to be left but are really
failures of leftism anyway a caller
really didn't like that he says it
doesn't exist he's furious with me take
a listen to this did I just hear you
correctly say that some people on the
left
I mean regimes they won't call them
totalitarian regimes but in the
interests of claiming to be for
Socialism or against American
imperialism they will end up supporting
those very things for real David yeah no
that's wrong you're 110 wrong that makes
no sense at all what some people on the
left like me
are against fighting with Russia because
we don't like our imperialistic attitude
that's a different issue and as I've
said that I literally addressed this you
can't just say I'm against American
imperialism so we want to just say
whatever Putin is doing is fine you can
condemn something Putin does while
saying I don't want the US involved for
example you can condemn the insanity of
the Chavez Maduro regimes in Venezuela
while saying I don't want the U.S
picking a leader I don't want the U.S
pushing regime change you it I don't
these folks get so triggered by this
attitude that part that you said was
correct
but not some people on the left aren't
paper of totalitarian regimes that makes
no [ __ ] sense again they would deny
that they are authorities and I by the
way I I did the other thing is I didn't
say totalitarian I said authoritarian so
it's like this is this is the perfect
example of someone denying reality
and misstating my position but you know
it's I'm used to it by now
they're not they're not leftists if they
are they're people on the right only
writers will be in favor of [ __ ] like
that
that's actually a really good point I
believe that a lot of these so-called
leftists who say Putin's not bad and
Bashar al-assad's not bad and maduro's
not bad and Castro was fine I I that's
my position is they're not really on the
left
they insist that they are but I would
actually agree inadvertently with the
caller I don't think those folks are
actually leftists anyway
that's a perfect example of what I've
been telling you guys about we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the believed Front Runners
for Joe Biden's Supreme Court pick we're
going to talk about the hilarity that is
developed with Glenn yunkin's tip line
to snitch on teachers it's actually
hilarious and we will talk about
problems with the child tax credit
problems with the child tax credit in
terms of it actually being distributed
to people we're going to talk about
confusion around that and much more on
today's bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com to get instant access we
will see you then or on tomorrow's show
foreign